mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
in square abcd construct a e and a f as
shown so that af bisects angle ead
if b e is equal to 36 and fd is equal to
64. solve for the length of ae
i received many emails with similar
problem suggestions and there's also a
similar problem on the youtube channel
maths smart
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve the problem
and i'm going to present one method that
involves outside the box thinking i'm
also going to present two methods that
involve inside the box thinking
but let's get started on the method
using outside the box thinking
we'll first label some of these angles
suppose eaf is equal to theta
because af is an angle bisector fad must
be equal to theta
next we have right angles in this square
which means afd is equal to 90 degrees
minus theta
then since angle a is a right angle we
have 90 degrees minus two theta over
here here we have another right angle at
b and this final angle b e a must be
equal to two theta
so here's the trick
we'll take triangle abe and rotate it 90
degrees about a clockwise
this will go outside the box
now let's take a look at this
construction
first of all we have a right angle here
because we've rotated a right triangle
next d and b prime will be coincidence
this is the image of b
and this is possible because a b and a d
are equal to each other in a square
this is where point e will go and we'll
label that as e prime
now this will be equal to 36 this is b
prime e prime
here we copy over the angle
now ae is equal to ae prime because
we've simply rotated this length
next we look at triangle afe prime
we'll calculate that f a e prime is
equal to 90 degrees minus theta
we have two angles of equal measure and
therefore these sides opposite them will
be equal to each other
so ae prime is equal to fe prime
and now f e prime must be equal to 64
plus 36 which is equal to 100. therefore
ae prime is also equal to 100 which
means ae is equal to 100 and that's the
answer
it's a very clever way using outside the
box thinking
now let's do some inside the box
thinking
first we use the same diagram with the
angles now suppose the side of the
triangle is equal to x so if a d is
equal to x then a b is also equal to x
in this triangle we have the tangent of
theta is equal to 64 over x
in triangle abe we have the tangent of 2
theta is equal to x over 36
we'll now use the tangent double angle
formula and substitute that in
now recall tangent of theta is equal to
64 over x so we can substitute that into
this formula
we then multiply the numerator and
denominator by x squared so we simplify
this fraction a little bit
now notice that the x terms will cancel
out
and then we can cross multiply and then
solve for x squared
we're not going to go any further we'll
just go with x squared the reason is
we'll now look at triangle abe
and we can calculate ae using the gogu
theorem a e squared is equal to x
squared plus 36 squared so we substitute
in for x squared
and now
this particular expression should be a
familiar expression
we can factor this out
it'll be exactly equal to the quantity
64 plus 36 squared
so ae squared is equal to this square we
take the square root of both sides and
we get ae is equal to 64 plus 36 which
is equal to 100 and once again we arrive
at the same answer but this time using
inside the box thinking
now there's a final way to solve this
problem using alkashi's law of cosines
i'm going to present this method because
it's the way that i solve the problem
so first we'll go ahead and label the
diagram with a side length of x
this means ec will be equal to x minus
36 and cf will be equal to x minus 64.
now construct ef and examine triangle
aef
we'll use el kashi's law of cosines and
the side opposite the angle theta
that'll be ef
so ef squared is equal to ae squared
plus af squared minus 2 times ae times
af times the cosine of theta
now in triangle afd we can calculate
that the cosine of theta is equal to x
over af
if we substitute that into the formula
we can then cancel out the af term and
what simplifies to the following form
we can then use the gogu theorem to
calculate ef squared we can then
calculate a e squared we can then
calculate a f squared
so we're going to substitute these into
our first formula at the top
when we do that we get the following
equation
this simplifies tremendously
compare these two terms
the x squared and the 36 squared will
cancel out and we'll be left with
negative 2 times 36 times x
in these two terms the x squared terms
and 64 square terms will cancel out and
we're left with negative 2 times 64
times x
so our equation simplifies to the
following form we then factor out
negative 2x on both sides since x is not
equal to zero it's the side length of
the square we can cancel out negative 2x
on both sides and we then get ae is
equal to 36 plus 64 which is exactly
equal to 100 and like magic we've solved
the problem once again
i think this is a really neat problem
and i'm sure there are many other ways
to solve it but i hope you enjoyed a
little bit of outside the box and inside
the box thinking
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you